bonjour à tous et bienvenue à tous il me
coupe la parole
waouh il a le record du coupage défense
me regarder dans ce deuxième épisode
c'est une manie je vais pas dernière il
vit à presque deux ans les gars le temps
passe très vite c'était il ya un an et
huit mois on a fait une vidéo qui
s'appelait qui possède le meilleur jeu
le concept de cette vidéo je le rappelle
mais il était extrêmement simple chacun
notre tour on va présenter un jouer
devant un jury constitué des deux autres
personnes ce qui ne présente pas de
jouer j'ai l'impression que ça fait huit
ans mais effectivement c'est pas beau ça
à la fin de cette présentation les deux
autres noterons la prestation du gars
qui représentait son jouet ok sur 10
le gagnant de la vidéo est celui qui
aurait eu la meilleure moyenne comment
choisis qui va présenter en premier sans
jouer bah c'est moi est ce que vous
venez du lourd non pas trop de sucre le
sort de tout ça
[Musique]
petite nouveauté l'entrée dans la salle
compte pour la prestation à temps il a
déjà pris là je crois il est gay boulot
messieurs vont maxence et imax les cols
roulés ça ne va très bien même si c'est
gentil est-ce que messieurs quand vous
étiez petit vous ça vous arrive est
cassé vous jouez et casser les parents
où il était au mont sont des punitions
tu vas au coin non non c'est le cycle de
vie d'un jouet tu vas dorthe messieurs
voici le jouet incassable
[Musique]
passons maintenant aux confusions
je pense que vous l'avoir plus en fait
ok elle est vraiment un cas ce que c'est
pour sos je peux vous sollicité pour
jouer parce qu'il attendait pas mais bon
il faut l'offrir à mickael carrick tous
déçus mais on va le tirer
tu le stand est ce que vous pouvez faire
ça et moi je peux m'asseoir dessus aussi
pas de problème dernière donc je vais
mal et je pense que c'est nous qui
sommes engagés envers nous on va
peut-être se situe à la main soit dessus
au fusil
non je suis assise de là je suis assis
dessus la cfu il a beaucoup mais il se
met en place
et voilà ok allez me comporter un peu
indéfini importants congés policiers le
match que tu peux tu peux faire un noeud
des gars aussi voilà faut savoir si tu
as un accident c'est à dire un petit
problème ça se garer sans peut être sûr
que dans dont deux heures j'ai plus la
main c'est pas beau ça sympa ouais je
peux dire quelque chose
oui alors déjà tu as une prestance qui
est remarquable c'est vrai c'est grâce
au col roulé ça ensuite sur le jouer ce
que je veux dire c'est que ça m'a
surpris fm on n'en voit pas tu peux nous
l'envoyer dans la gueule je peux à tout
est fait ouais ça tu peux gagner des
points voie inverse la meilleure
division face est le meilleur jeu j'ai
quand même pu m'asseoir dessus premier
degré la voiture je me suis quand même
si le premier degré parce que les gens
ils étaient abasourdis de voir cette
prestation la paix je pense que rien que
pour ça ça devrait peut-être influencé
la note je veux pas trop en dire mais
bon t'as dit menacé deux points en moins
pour moi dur c'est pas le jouet coup de
coeur
d'accord je te le dis j'en ai vu passer
dans cette émission des jouets il a son
truc il ya un truc et ça me plaît la kio
devoir en fait j'ai envie de faire
ceinture les axes ans comment il
s'appelle la peine non
super amstrong on peut encore le passe
en premier après on peut bien mettre des
hautes notes aux autres gens ouais c'est
cool
raté est-ce qu'on peut mettre la note
peut-être annonces légales j'ai même à
mon oral le bac j'ai prescrit c'est
comme ça vous rendez pas qu'on vous
exactement ont délibéré moi je trouve ce
jeu assez sympa c'est surprenant je
savais pas qu'il existait une malle et
s'est testé tout schéma soirs de suite
où je suis assez content pour moi c'est
un set j'ai adoré j'ai adoré pour
plusieurs raisons j'ai adoré parce que
le jeu m'a surpris j'ai rigolé en fait
il m'a procuré de l'émotion dans sa
proposition il ya eu de la performance
j'ai une grande sympathie pour toi donc
c'est cette eau
ben merci les gars on est raccord
bureau bien joué je m'attendais
honnêtement à pire et je suis vraiment
très honoré non mais c'est surtout me
gêne j'imagine pas les gens qui le garde
[Musique]
je pense que ce musical tu penses ouah
qui n'a jamais rêvé incroyable c'est pas
genre un tapis de bain c'est pas un
tapis c'est pas un revêtement pour votre
cuisine c'est un piano qui marche
je suis encore pas tu as bien la péter
chou très peu on peut faire le plus fort
encore on peut faire des accords wahou
la mineure
sol majeur bah c'est récent vous
connaissiez les morceaux quatre mains au
piano oui et bien là on peut faire des
morceaux huit pieds je vais essayer
venait pas du tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi passage que vous avez juré peut
montrer une option où il va y aller on
peut enregistrer ses morceaux donc là ce
que j'aimerais qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
enregistre prochain dessus il qu'on veut
mettre sur sam club
voilà c'est fait c'est un plaisir aux
gens attention ça marche avec les mains
on a enregistré partie
je
ouais à l'estrie mais ça foyer alors
j'ai pas fini la présentation est bon
mais coupée pour vous amuser ce que je
comprends c'est sympa parce que voilà ça
stimule la créativité chez l'enfant très
tôt mais dans la musique très tôt il se
met est repris par les mélodies a donc
voilà je pense que ces pianos peut
beaucoup aider
que ce soit pour les parents pour les
enfants ça marche à pile quand c'est
fini hop là qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
un supporter et on en entend plus parler
tu peux le mettre en couverture et quand
les gens qui font des kalimbas sacrés de
la musique tu joue super bien du don on
dirait un balai c'est génial maxence
continue vive le rugby lostorf par une
super note je cherchais pas comment
délibéré ça j'ai fais quoi moi tu sais
ça fait une saison que dans cette
émission en une émission j'ai jamais
ressenti ça mon gars parce que j'ai vécu
là tout à l'heure avec toi je pense ça
va faire partie des midis meilleur
souvenir de ma vie et pour moi rien que
pour ça ça vaut un magnifique 8,62 il
d'ailleurs pas content pendant 29
minutes 5 sec du projet 8 500 brouillard
je suis très heureux alors je vais
délibéré au 6 et l'instant même où j'ai
vu le jouer j'ai voulu l'essayer on sait
ce que c'est il est apportée
différemment c'est prendre des choses
des combats et les refaire évoluer
encore une fois encore une fois et
encore une fois
moi j'ai envie de me mettre à la gym
mais encore une fois j'étais content
quand même du coup le temps je joue j'ai
passé un merveilleux moment avec vous je
suis vraiment heureux suis vraiment en
fait un peu trop
c'est à toi mon prochain est long et
vous allez devoir participer
ok ok
[Musique]
bonsoir ça est-ce que vous avez déjà
vécu la solitude oui ce que je vais vous
présenter c'est plus un concept c'est
plus c'est de la compagnie c'est de la
compagnie c'est quelque chose qui va
être interactif et j'ai envie de vous
présenter un petit peu plus comme une
énigme noche une très bonne note là
l'objet est un animal ont joué
évidemment à sa petit oiseau c'est un
hibou et c'est thibout il est là il est
avec toi
il imitait mec terrain fleury non t'as
pas osé juste ramener refermer non
l'objectif c'est qu'ils reçoivent assez
d'amour il va s'envoler comme si et
seulement si il reçoit assez d'amour
quoi voici le liboux il est tout mignon
les quais qui soulève donner un nom
jérôme ça va tu ne rentres pas alors je
vous présente jérôme chacun de ses yeux
indique une émotion quand il est blessé
qu'il a froid qui veut venir
qu'est ce que tu lui feras ce qui vous
salue gérard il a foulé gérone tu les
touffes max tu étouffes la j'étouffe
peut-être je souffre des sujets là j'ai
le souffle aux chômeurs et le but place
et vous devez le faire voler à vous de
me dire quelle couleur deux yeux il est
et je vous dis qu'est ce qu'il a il est
rouge a accueilli les roses rouges là il
est rouge les rouges il est rejoint je
me devais de crise il est triste il
je fais mon truc et les blocs aux trois
quarts des bisous je sais mais libéré je
vais capricieux et normand il à chaud là
n'est pas l'essentiel c'est qu'il
s'apprêtait à s'envoler
leila froid faut poser la balle au fond
non non non non non ils sont venus on en
a même je pense que ça fait quand ils
sont au volant
par contre au nom et pour tenir ce
domaine aussi gelé taper comme ça il va
il ressent des choses je comprends pas
c'est comme ça que ce trade not least
une abandonnent déjà ramène le ici on
peut pas juste le démonter vous diront
que les g7 communiquée que mon vol de
l'unc et j'essaie de parler à mon fils
était de me bouger quoi il est triste il
faut caresser mouvement lui donne que de
l'amour il nous en donne très
je crois qu'il faut que cette situation
ni non mashaie mais c'est elle qui nous
attendait mais je vais vous faire la
démo ça il va voler vous allez voir
rouge
or il est triste bon en même temps tu es
une merde je suis le faire voler
je le vois déjà il va essayer toute la
soirée c'est moi je vais me faire un
café c'est quand je veux bien la sas
progrès je suis désolé mais moi je vais
aux toilettes on reviendra mais ses
parents vous n'êtes pas là il vole à bas
les gens mais je le faire voler je le
sois volta guette les gars allez je vais
oublier se plonger le j'avais oublié
apprivoiser alors ça à vis à vis du
progrès ou pas depuis
oui on regarde vol faux pas mais qu oui
quoi
pourquoi
croire au nom voyez le moment il alors
des mitraillettes technologies non
retour dans leur tente allez mon bras
mais ok t'as craqué le truc non non j'ai
compris il suffit de devenir folle moi
c'est cette phase là là ça va
[Musique]
le texte un très chic bon mec
c'est un oeil neuf sur dix c'est ptet
pas au bout t'es pas au bout de tes
émotions ça va vraiment sonné comme une
phrase qu'on entend très souvent dans ce
genre de télé crochet mais j'ai jamais
vu ça
c'est une belle leçon au fait ce que tu
arrives en nous présentant ce jouet a
l'air con en train de vivre la 2020 où
on commence à se questionner à dire bah
est ce que les robots vont pas prendre
une place importante dans le société
mais l'humour transcende l'amour pardon
et l'amour
je crois que c'est mieux quand on doit
composer même c'est quoi 900 mineurs en
tout cas bravo c'est moi j'ai approché
applaudir les et on ne voit plus je m'en
fous je suis hors change pas garde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non je déconne je vais présenter mon
deuxième jour où ça va en ce moment je
sais pas si vous avez suivi l'actualité
c'est les grèves c'est si oui oui ok
j'attends des réponses du coup qu'on
voit en fait que vous faites quoi vous
vous dites ok y'a pas de métro ya rien
tu fais quoi bah une trottinette il dit
ouais trottinette dans cette voie ferrée
l'eau à vélo ça prend la place sa peur
de le faire rouler c'est un peu galère
tu vois ça dépend koala roumec s'apprend
pas seulement place lui à votre avis
combien de roue sur moi sous - bahia
celle de la chaise hyacinthe branche
donc il ya cinq ou lettres sur la chaise
roulante et te lis quoi ta digoin liste
où figure toi que non ça c'est mieux que
de l'iss car je collais fixé sur mes
chaussures à a donc imaginé me oil et
hop là et je vais au boulot
hop comme ça et en plus à garder la nuit
on peut me repérer facilement parce que
je suis un peu disco
quand je roule ça ça peut aller mais
lourd hop comme ça les petits trottoirs
toi toi tu en fais beaucoup trop ouais
mais tous les jours là je suis venu
comme ça tu à l'heure mais c'est pas
plus de prendre ça parce que de façon tu
dois les mettre et enlever autant
prendre déroulement de ce que rihanna je
peux le faire en deux secondes
la sueur va dehors cetto nous montrer
ouais
orgasme on peut noter on peut noter on
peut noter alors qu'il faut donc écoule
bon à sa note bien je le sens là le
tracé j'apprécie les forts donc j'ai mis
1,5
quand même écouter un petit peu
compliqué parce que je suis globalement
d'accord tout ce que tout ce que tu as
pu dire pareil si ça reste comme un
objet cool car c'est un objet de
déplacement et en fait quand on parle de
jouer j'aime bien qu'on apporte une
autre notion une nouvelle option que
juste tu te poses tu joues tu vois ce
que je veux dire tu m'écoutes maxence
l'histoire tu perdent pas de points mais
c'est très con jacques y en a pas
beaucoup
bref il y aurait eu 25 sur 10 hockey
[Musique]
vous pouvez regarder c'est moi je n'ai
pas fini mon dessin je vais faire des
yeux qui regardait pas c'est amusant on
aime tous on aime tous les blagues bien
d'essayer d'en faire une
on aime tous les blagues et les petites
banques alors vous avez tous achetés
déjà le fameux paquet de chewing gum qui
envoie un coup d'électricité vous avez
tous a plaidé jean étudiant e bas alors
monsieur connard jamais fait et
d'aujourd'hui tels relou c'est un jouet
sympa comme ce qu'il est à la fois je
peux parler oui il est à la fois ludique
il est à la fois technologique on n'est
pas sur le level d'un certain hibou mais
pas loin
et on peut avec cet objet piéger les
gens tout se passe grâce à cette
télécommande réunions familiales
vous devez être dans votre chambre parce
que maman veut parler à ses amis
tranquillement on amène sa devant maman
on appuie la et home et abuse toi tu
payes ton part de chez toi re up les
copains la maman sorte on peut enfin
sortir de sa chambre est retourné sur
l'ordi justice quelque chose je vois ça
sur mon homme je l'achète c'est ce qui
s'est passé je n'ai rien de plus à vous
dire je n'ai rien de plus à ses
commandes et que c'est pas du fait qu un
peu loin je pensais à way à la portée
mais ça marche très bien le cas c'est
une belle découverte
en vrai je me suis cassé un kaka qui
bouge qui bouge ta paix pour mal à
dieulefit ce choix j'ai pas ou quoi j'ai
fini ma prestation vous en pensez ce que
vous voulez mais c'est de la merde c'est
un jouet de merde quoi moi si j'étais
quelqu'un à qui regarde la vidéo je me
devrais peut-être que bon la note mérité
date au moins 8 après je vais pas
influencer les gens du jury mais il a
tout se joue et vous le savez tous je
vous adore je suis déçu de la
performance mais il est tellement génial
incroyable qu'en fait je suis prêt à
investir dans ce jouet où qu'il aille
plus loin tu proposerait pas ça chez
yoko ono comme ça il ya un truc à une
collab secret crevaison
c'est pour ça que je lui ai donné un 6
et demi sur dix qui relativement bonne
note c'est un 13 tu vois très samba
tu m'a ôté les mots de la bouche je
pense qu'on a tous été surpris moi ça
m'a fait beaucoup rire est ce que ça
peut ne pas faire venir quelqu'un je le
suspense
me terrifie henry acheteurs sont nés
d'être là jean pierre pierre de von rath
pour un jouet blague pour de la merde
hausse est la bonne mais coûté très
heureux sur amazon messieurs pour ce
deuxième jouer j'aimerais vous poser
quelque chose qui est encore brice des
limites détourne les codes
il y en avait d'autres anéantir des
barrières quant aux portes de jouer on
se restreint forcément a souvent une
chose en particulier
mais un jouet c'est finalement plein de
choses à jouer ça peut être un gadget un
petit ips de vie tu peux jouer avec
beaucoup de choses ce petit bout qui
veulent que je vous propose est là c'est
un gadget qui va vous rendre mais cool
tout se passe avec votre téléphone vous
êtes au restaurant vous avez fini de
manger et c'est le moment de payer on
doit veiller aux gars vous prenez la
carte
oui génial ma carte est bloqué dans mon
téléphone
elle est là et tu fais pas de souci
tenez c'est un tour de magie qui vient
de faire bah oui c'est un type school ou
c'est juste cool je voulais voir autre
chose
germaine tu fasses light ont permis avec
un permis avec ton permis j'ai pas le
permis moins c'est quoi j'ai pas le
permis c zéro non on peut le faire avec
peu de choses moi par exemple j'avais ça
en regard de maxence tu peux que tu vas
peut-être reconnaître vas-y au comunale
regarde au c'est très stylé 7/6 6 andric
je sais ça descenderie qui fait dans sa
tournée mac sous les eaux mais voilà ne
jetez pas vos mégots par terre arrêté
jeter vos mégots par terre c'est simple
tout ça coûte rien de faire ça et
surtout le tessin ce activement en
faisant ça tu vois une petite pièce d'un
euro si tu veux donner un euro et edf
est cool on peut couper ça et être
couilles il leur est il le fait pour
être cool très cool ça m'a surpris que
tu te ramène avec un truc qui n'est pas
un jouet si je trouve ça très audacieux
et en vrai j'ai trouvé le côté tips un
peu cool même si je comprends les doutes
que tu pouvais avoir du style bah c'est
pas vraiment un joueur extérieur
justement je me suis dit que
je méritais un bon 8 et demi son audace
tout le monde va s'y met tout le monde à
faire son petit truc sympa pour faire
rigoler pour faire sourire et pour ça je
mets un 9 sur 10 aux développeurs donc
dès maintenant pour seb
il a utilisé une appli qui a été créée
par d'autres étaient probablement temps
pas plus payante mais j'aimerais quand
même pour sap reste à lui mettre en
oeuvre les nuits sur 10 parce qu'il
n'est pas magicien et que j'y ai cru à
fond je n'y croyais mais mais j'en doute
pas
[Musique]
je préviens je vous dis j'ai vu j'ai vu
des pieds mais jamais comment commencer
là c'est encore pire
je sais encore moins quand on entre le
direct ce que reconnaissait super smash
à cet argent oui ça se fume de tarzan
mesdames et messieurs a une
particularité c'est que regarder salut
squeeze celle du cep
quand vous allez alors dit que d'être
tout une voix un peu plus grave par the
[Musique]
new delhi autre chose un mot espadrilles
c'est tout de faire tout ce que vous
voulez les gars mais mesdames et
messieurs je vais finir sa démonstration
parce qu'il à notre particularité est le
tarzan su que des fois il est tout seul
chez lui il s'ennuie un peu
du coup il baisse son short c'est
dégradant
[Musique]
ça
c'est la chose reste sûre protoss faut
savoir que ce jeu était bannie en 1999
et du coup bah évidemment il ya des
processeurs et moi je suis partie des
possesseurs de bon franchement histoire
je note c'est malheureusement pas le
slip originale la personne n'avait pas
le site
on me redonne non mais si mais si grande
prestation
l'histoire est le fait de l'avoir
trouvée alors le tout tout tout j'étais
dans une démarche vous cherchez des
jouets way qui est un peu vieux ou des
trucs qui ont existé plutôt que
d'acheter des écoutes et les amis la
moyenne de nos notes s'affiche à l'écran
ça c'est le classement d'après les notes
attribuées mais moi aujourd'hui dans mon
cas j'aimerais remettre quand même le
prix le gagnant un match sauf évidemment
pour ses prestations
la dernière fois d'après les notes tué
était le grand gagnant
j'avais fini premier vrai oui c'est vrai
que finalement le montage ont été
deuxièmes et gt3 la dernière fois les
gens avaient pu voter pour élire le
gagnant et c'était celle qu'ils avaient
réussi à 100 m brasse aux jeux d'eau
n'est même plus un évidement vous allez
aussi voter on veut on veut avoir cet
avis puisque le joug était bien est-ce
que voter selon vos critères à vous via
le lien twitter dans les décisions que
la dernière fois
c'est un super concert que j'adore vous
venez faire ça quand vous voulez ça me
fait mourir de rire avec plaisir et puis
s'était pas passé voir bien sûr la
chaîne de seb la chaîne de maxence et
puis à très vite pour les prochaines
vidéos au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]